all right guys bang-bang I've got Tim
we've got a lot to cover today so thanks
much for doing this
my pleasure absolutely you are in Austin
Texas what's a Cove in nineteen
quarantine like down in Texas so I run a
defensive tactics and security
consulting company out of out of
property that I live on I live on land
so it's kind of like a ranch in a farm
no so I have maybe 900 pounds a hunted
meat I have wells and solar you know
like my my day to day has not changed
much I have to interact with people less
not because of me but because in bed so
uh yeah like I still shoot three times a
week I still train six times a day or
six times a week you know I'm still up
early in bed late so I thought I saw you
posted on Instagram you got your
chickens a new coop and everything it
seems like just business as usual well
those ladies are lucky man they got like
tripled there there's their square
footage so I love it drats
but before we get into the conversation
kind of round a personal freedom civil
liberties maybe just give us a quick run
down to your background you you've done
a whole bunch of different things and
then we can get into kind of what
sheepdog is as well okay so I guess I
have been in like the protecting serving
and saving business my entire life my
first job was a firefighter EMT I did
that from 18 until 23 I was in grad
school when 9/11 happened I had just
finished the police academy
and I went from my job to the recruiters
office about ten a.m. to stand in line
with about a thousand other people to
try and enlist so that was my 911 on 911
they gave me a deferred delayed
enlistment so I could finish grad school
and and then I went in as an 18 X ray
which is a Special Forces recruit which
means I get to go straight to Special
Forces
selection and if I get selected after
basic infantry school and Airborne
School and a couple of preparation
schools
if I get selected I get to go to Special
Forces training if I finished Special
Forces training I get to go to an Oda so
that was 16 years ago that I was
selected and for the past 15 and a half
years I have been a green beret and
filled the job of a sniper
counterterrorism hostage rescue and a
lot of FID which is foreign internal
defense and Jay sets joint combine
exercises for training well I'm throwing
those acronyms out there because those
will come become relevant as we start
talking about developing countries that
are kind of following our playbook about
when to grab liberties so I've been in
in places like Trinidad Tobago and
Jamaica and Dominican Republic after
horrific earthquakes and tsunamis and I
have seen what governments can do in
these times of crisis and obviously
being alive and being an adult during
the time of the Patriot Act when 9/11
kicked off so aside from my military
career I have I'm an entrepreneur
so I own six different businesses three
of them are in kind of what one is a
government contractor so we go and do
jobs for the government security jobs
and then we have a security consulting
company so if somebody comes to us and
says hey I have a problem whether that's
private investigating bodyguard work or
physical protection of them like what's
something we also do and then we also
have a training company where we try
clast year we train 2,000 Americans in
how to deal with a situation like we're
experiencing right now it's like that is
my full-time job that's what I do the
other companies are Ranger up which is a
military apparel line will be shoes
which is I think the best kind of
tactical shoes out there and then
relentless which is a full-body meal
supplement replacement system for idiots
like me that travel and work
a lot yeah so you know as kind of
somebody from afar I think one way to
summarize a lot of what you've done is
just around like individual
responsibilities and you had the
military experience you've done that for
awhile you've got these private
companies obviously you're operating in
kind of various ways but you also took a
period of time and fought in the UFC etc
maybe just describe a little bit about
that period of time that we can kind of
wrap it all into what you're doing now
yes it's hilarious I like skip over what
I guess a lot of people know me for I
fought professionally for 17 years I
fought for the world title and
Strikeforce twice try part for the UFC I
fought for Strikeforce on carpi FL I
fight for the WC so the largest fighting
organizations on the planet I was a
contender in all of those different
fight leagues and then I did a bunch of
television on History Channel and
Discovery Channel I had my own show
called hard to kill which was kind of
survival ish dirty jobs meets like jobs
that will kill you kind of and then a TV
show where I went around the world
trying to hunt Nazis and guys that maybe
escaped the Nuremberg trials yeah
you've lived a life I think a lot of
people wish they could but I think your
resounding message is you've got to kind
of put the work in to be prepared and
you're still operating today as a green
beret yeah absolutely yeah I'm actually
just got back my one of one of my latter
when the last flights in from where I
was I think there were two flights after
the fight that I was on to come back to
kind of pre Co vid so I mean I barely
snuck in before shut down of
international flights from these places
as an aside I read an article this
morning there's a couple that went to
the Maldives on their honeymoon and they
didn't get on the last flight and so
they now are the only people at the
resort but they're having to continue to
pay every night and they're afraid it's
gonna bankrupt them and so they're like
stuck in paradise was kind of the
thought process which sounds cool until
you realize like hey that's pretty
expensive and there's no end in sight of
when you
come back yeah um that's that coming
back to individual responsibilities of
like yeah this is really nice I'm just
gonna you know take care of myself and
and stay in this like resort place until
it doesn't work out and you forget that
you have big responsibilities for sure
so I want to kind of get into this
conversation around you are one of the
strongest proponents and most vocal
proponents of kind of the American
ideals American freedoms etc you've
literally dedicated your life in various
ways to either one protecting that right
as kind of a direct action in military
exception but also to through sheepdog
and the training you guys do training
both law enforcement and also just
average Americans on how to protect
themselves their families and those
ideals but you mentioned this idea that
during times of crisis there are
incredible overreach by governments not
just the United States government just
governments around the world let's kind
of go back in history and then maybe
bring it to the present day whether you
want to talk about the Patriot Act or
some of the things that you've seen in
other countries where that overreach has
kind of presented itself and how you've
experienced that or seen it yeah I think
we're the greatest examples truthfully
Adolf Hitler Adolf Hitler used an
economic opportunity where Germany at
the time was destitute they were hurting
and they really had no esprit de corps
about who they were in an identity and
well I think 90 95 percent of Germans in
1943 would be against the gas scene of
Jews they were carried in this momentum
and this power and this thrust of
nationalism versus patriotism those are
kind of different things
and and also the the cry of the general
population of needing to do something
and fear
so after World War one you know one of
the most horrific wars in human history
we're really mekin where we had really
mastered the art of killing other humans
with gas and machines and bombs this was
the first war where
we could kill in a mass scale and the
horrors coming back from that there was
fear and and some even some of the same
fears that we have right now is am I
gonna have money to pay for my food am I
gonna have money to pay for my home am I
gonna have money to pay for clothes for
my kid to go to school those same fears
existed then and the Germans the German
people were running for solutions and
they didn't know what those were and up
came lots of different possibilities and
one of those was the nationalist
Socialist Party which was led by Adolf
Hitler and we saw where that went we
could go time and time and time again
throughout history where we see people
that are struggling people that are
sometimes starving sometimes just in
fear and they are looking for a solution
to be given to them long story short is
nothing can ever be given to you that's
it like everything that you want and
everything that you think that you want
is really on the far side of hard work
if they're gonna give it to you that
means they have to take it from somebody
else there it doesn't like money just
doesn't come up from from nowhere
they're like ah we now have free
education or we now have like free
health care like if it's free that means
they took it from somebody and freedoms
are one of the most difficult things to
perceive as a commodity like food and
education and healthcare those are like
those aren't these extra central
concepts those are tangible things that
we can we can pick up right that we can
go and like get a prescription or that
we can put our mouth but like the
freedom of speech or the freedom to
paddleboard or the freedom to assemble
those are things that we think we
understand until the government says no
you can't do them and then you go oh
wait how does this really apply to me I
have you know working in South America
Argentina Chile Venezuela also three
great examples just in the past ten
years where we have seen through
economic crisis people give up their
civil liberties because they think
they're trying to find a better so
but that better solution ends up being
this looks like horrific nightmare where
you're living in purgatory we're like oh
I don't know if I have enough money for
food now it's like not only do I not
have enough money I'm not allowed to go
buy it I have to go wait in mind in
front of a store with 2,000 people in
front of me for a chance to get some
because the government is gonna provide
us yeah that was kind of a tirade but it
no historical examples but but what I
think that you're really highlighting
here is there's what I'll call like
overt
you know kind of stealing of freedom
where literally I'm gonna say you can't
go do something right and you know and I
both know like there's a lantern in the
sand right and so Tim you can no longer
leave the state of Texas would be like
an example of something but there's also
things that are done kind of in the
shadows right this is where you get you
know in a country like Venezuela kind of
the hyperinflation what it's really
doing is it's just stealing the wealth
of you know the average citizen and it's
enriching people who own the real assets
the government or the dictator etc and
so I think what you're really talking
about is less about the structural like
economic things that are done because
those aren't really immediately seen by
the population they just know hey breads
a little bit you know more expensive
than it was yesterday and after you know
a couple of months of that they realize
wait a second it's doubled in price but
the things that are really really I
think aggressive and especially happened
in times of crisis or these like over
encroachments on freedom and so we're
seeing a couple of examples now and I'll
just kind of go through a few examples
that we're seeing maybe you can riff on
them so the one that got me to reach out
to you about doing this was uh there's
this paddleboarder in LA he's in the
water an absolute epic video where
you've got I think two or three
lifeguard boats like flying around the
ocean by the pier trying to get this guy
and he and he's just giving him the
moves man I mean he's just paddling
right around in the books and they
eventually caught them and arrested them
but just kind of your take on it was
like hey enjoy your 60 day free trial of
communism so like what's kind of
thoughts there well that there is some
great response where people like
yourself recognize that so communism
unless you've been to places that are
socialist or communist in nature talking
you know people talk about Sweden or
Finland or Denmark is that's all I'm
talking about I'm talking about like the
Taliban it can be a form of socialism
think about that al-qaeda and Isis could
be can be forms of socialism more so
than any of these like North East and
North Western European countries so then
that is where you're kind of entire
existence is is being dictated by you
for the greater good of everyone else
with you so the government tells you
what you're supposed to do how you're
supposed to do it and when you're
supposed to do it and the reason for
them telling you this is so that it's
it's fair and even for everybody there's
there some to inherent problems with
that one it removes all individual
motivation for success so I have no
incentive to go and be successful at
something because if I'm incentivized
and I get more than the next person they
have to take that away from me so the
next time next to me gets the same
amount regardless of how much work he
did so that removes my initiative and my
incentive to go do something this
specific paddleboarder you're joking
about leaving Texas as a lioness and
that is a line in the sand now people
from Louisiana cannot come into Texas
like we I mean we're literally talking
about East and West Berlin right now
where the government just said here is
this arbitrary line you people are not
allowed to cross it not not for any
other reason besides we said so and it's
for your best it's we promised it is for
them it's for the best of everybody not
for you not for you necessarily I don't
care if your grandma is going through
chemo and it and you're the caretaker
and you live in Beaumont and you're
trying to get to Shreveport that's not
my problem really this is just for
everybody so you just you're just gonna
have to let your grandma die because we
care about everybody
not you so paddleboarder la it's cool
that you're bringing up LA because that
had another specific example of a direct
infringement the LA County Sheriff he
told all of his deputies to go to the
gun stores
and closed them all down because he did
not think there are central forms of
business so essential businesses were
ones that kind of sustain your living
and your kind of health he looked at gun
stores as not one of those things and he
told his deputies to go and close those
things down
fortunately superior courts and federal
government's can't panic stepped in and
said hey you can't do that you have to
allow these guys continue to operate
business and we do view visas as
essential businesses even more hilarious
is he circumvented us and tried to go
through a court of appeals within
California to then
limits what they were allowed to do and
then he sent in business inspectors to
make sure that those specific businesses
were following the CDC whu-oh and and
state guidelines so then they could shut
them down on you know like process into
indiscretions about like the distance
that one customer was standing from the
next customer insanity so back to LA
dude is on the Pacific Ocean on a
paddleboard the only people within maybe
a thousand meters are the people trying
to arrest him so I'm not talking six
feet we're talking like a thousand
meters you know like just over a half a
mile three quarters a mile and they're
all like there's lifeguards trying to
come in there's LA County sheriff's
deputies on the beach with bullhorns
there's a LA County boat cruising out on
the on the far side of the breakers and
the crime this dude committed was he was
paddle boarding so if we're gonna try
and say okay Patriot Act great example
of the government being okay let's go
grab as much as we possibly can
why they motivations were pure I think
that they're trying to do the right
thing which is trying to stop another
attack you can't help but but look at
the figure what was
star wars movie or Emperor Palpatine who
is like Darth Sidious that works dude
ever when when the Senate gives him like
the authority to go declare war and
start the Clone Army he's like Oh with
this great responsibility at the end of
these trying times I promise I will give
all of this power back and then he's
electrocuting people with his fingers
right like metaphorically that's
hilarious
in reality and historically that is
exactly what happens every single time
somebody gets power it's never giving
back and they they except in times of
these these extreme circumstances it's
always incremental right like the second
amendments nobody's ever gonna come kick
in the door and say give me all your
guns but what they will do is enact
another law and that's another
restriction enact another high-capacity
ban
we're gonna change the name of something
we're gonna add that this is the child
protection gun Safety Act we're going to
say that okay you can own your guns but
you can only buy this much ammo and then
you have to do a background check so
like every single time it's just a
little bit more a little bit more and
this is the constant struggle that we
have to push against and tell something
like this happens then the government
goes this is a great opportunity to take
whatever we can because it's like one
it's like it says all-you-can-eat buffet
give me the First Amendment give me the
SEC amend and give me the third
amendment matter of fact I'll just go
through every single one of them and
grab as much as I can this moment
because people are in fear and people do
dumb things when they're scared yeah one
of the things that is really interesting
so you talked about kind of that
Louisiana Texas border right one of the
other examples is in Rhode Island the
governor tried to shut the border right
and when she couldn't shut the border
lawyers based he said hey that's
unconstitutional she then went to okay
well I'm gonna do one better we're gonna
put police on the highway if they see
New York plates we're gonna pull those
people over for having New York plates
and then we're gonna take the military
and the police and we're gonna have them
patrol transportation hubs and oh by the
way if you're a citizen in Rhode Island
and you know somebody came here from New
York call us and we'll go visit them
yeah you do yeah we should take I don't
know what the emblem is for New York but
maybe like the Yankees or
like the Jets or something and we should
take that and have that showing onto
everybody shirts and like like in a
yellow material maybe even like a star
maybe not even like the New York Yankees
thing maybe just like a star like a Star
of David just haven't shown on their
shirts so then we know who they are and
we could just go grab them up nobody's
ever thought of that before no no so if
you then take it a step further rakes I
I agree with you that like the paddle
board things like pretty ridiculous and
you watch it and if you're watching it
from the the sense of like we're
spending all these resources and
literally there's boats chasing a paddle
boarder and he's kind of getting the
shakes like okay we can laugh about it
but there is some serious aspect to it
but then when you go to Kentucky where a
judge ordered a man to wear a
gps-enabled ankle bracelet because he
had been ordered to quarantine he had
been in contact with somebody who had
been infected and he kept violating it
so the solution here was let's literally
put an electronic tracker on your ankle
and therefore we'll know if you leave
quarantine or now it just feels like the
lawyers are gonna have a field day with
this stuff once it's all over yeah I I
hope they do while I hate that we're in
a litigious era of society and I think
that is another way that we're kind of
eroding I'm all for anytime you enact a
new law or set a new precedent an old
one has to go away
you know like any time you keep adding
on to this like you you get discount
compounded j-curve and then this
exponential growth of law happens and
then ultimately everything comes
crashing down because you know that's a
different conversation yeah a bunch of
problems the first is that when you
start looking as these these these
individual examples and use that as
leverage to hold a greater group of
people responsible that those are
incidental examples that they're like
that is not a representation of the
greater community right the greater
community is trying to do the right
thing but when you take individual
examples and use that an individual
example to
circumvent law and then try to take the
larger population and erode their
freedoms or their rights because of one
idiot and the greater people are letting
that happen yeah you can just get used
to more the same because once they do it
a few times they'll continue to do it
every single Avenue and an aspect they
can that they can grab yeah and this is
where I think you get kind of this
intersection of the personal
responsibility and the freedom right
what I mean by that is like you and I
are relatively young relatively healthy
compared to others and therefore we have
the responsibility to ensure those in
our lives are taken care of but also
you're taking risk if you outside today
and you contract coronavirus right
that's a choice you made you got
infected and you have to deal with the
ramifications and so I think that
there's this debate across society right
at what point are you endangering other
people versus just endangering yourself
and when you overlay the personal
responsibility most people actually are
doing the right thing but these you know
I call them like there's stupidity and
there's just douchebags and being stupid
or being a douchebag isn't illegal it's
just you're stupid or you're a douchebag
and so how you try to balance that in
society is it through social pressure
right or is it actually where people
eventually just turn is how I am so
fearful but I'm willing to give up my
freedom because I want to keep those
people in their apartments in their
homes etc it's just a really really kind
of bad conversation when people aren't
optimizing for the freedoms because
they're so overrun with the feet yeah I
I think that you should fear is the
worst emotion ever to base decisions
about freedoms off of right and when
we're so individual responsibility is it
my choice to go outside yes and the idea
of individual responsibility is so I'm a
libertarian like nothing crazy
libertarian maybe a little bit but I
believe that nobody should have a say in
what I do
u-unless what I do affects somebody else
negative and so if I go out and I get
Corona that's that's that's my problem
where Corona gets kind of gray hazy is
because there's the number of
asymptomatic people that there are where
you can contract Corona and I don't know
that I had forum and I can still go
transmit to other people so I'm
negatively impacting other people so
under this idea of kind of individual
responsibility I can't just have the
consequences for my actions just
happened to me
because supposedly and I'm putting a
little asterisk supposedly one gift 25
percent of people are asymptomatic so I
could if I don't know go out and spread
it to other what is I I think an element
that people are considering is the
beauty of capitalism and how capitalism
can really be the equal the equalizer to
this conversation where if you're
calling them douchebags or a selfish
person if you are seeing a business or a
person that you don't like what they're
doing you get to vote with your dollars
and that shapes the success and failure
of that business and I think a lot of
people have looked at entrepreneurs
people like me who have been saying we
are not thinking about the second third
order effects of this pandemic because
what I'm balancing is the cost of lives
versus what is the number of people that
are gonna die from the virus so that's
gonna be whatever hundreds of thousands
of people that might potentially and who
those people are versus the other group
of people in the second and third order
effects that could die from the not from
the virus but from the second third or
effects so you shut down I'm just going
to use Disneyland as an example so you
shut down Disneyland Disneyland
employees let's just say a hundred
thousand people
of those hundred thousand people how
many of those people had any savings in
their bank accounts not very much the
average American has about four hundred
dollars in his savings account his or
her savings account so that's not enough
to pay for one month run so if this goes
on for more than one month they can't
pay their rent so we fortunately are
able to I say fortunately asterisks we
can freeze evictions and bankruptcies so
me as a landlord I can't kick somebody
out because they're not paying me but I
know that they still will be paying me
and that person knows that that Talley
is continuing to grow and that hole that
they're in economically is going to
continue to get deeper not
socio-economic conditions are one of the
largest influences to suicide to
depression and to drug abuse so the poor
somebody gets the more often you see
depression you see suicide and you see
drug drug and alcohol abuse the
percentage of suicide grows as does so
the more drug abuse and alcohol abuse
service the more socioeconomically
disadvantaged somebody is the more
likely they are to have suicide so now
as this pendulum is swinging and the
second and third order effects of people
losing their homes after they've lost
their job the business is not going to
come back you know gum the McDonald's
that was on the corner it was already
barely making enough money as it was now
they're definitely not not going to be
making enough money they're just not
gonna Rio
you know McDonald's is gonna relocate to
a different place or maybe not in them
right Chipotle not gonna open they're
gonna pick and choose where these new
what stores are gonna be opening that is
gonna have a profound economic effect
and those people that have been were
destitute before now they're truly
struggling so it actually hurt my
feelings a little bit when I looked at
your comments when when you asked what
questions would we ask and one of the
guys said why is tim kennedy
so insensitive to the kind of like the
minorities or outliers of society truth
be told the second third or effects are
going to be more damaging to those
people than anybody else so if you if
you really strategic
and economically look at what I'm trying
to do and how I'm trying to save lives
in this conversation that we're having
we could seriously be losing way more
people through suicide drug drug
overdoses and alcohol abuse and the kids
that are gonna be homeless than like we
know what happens when somebody loses
their home like how hard it is to get
back off of the street now you're gonna
have how many kids that are gonna be
homeless
like nobody's even started to calculate
the economic effect of these second
third order problems I mean we're
talking way more than one or two hundred
thousand people way more you know we're
talking up into the millions
if this trajectory of what we're doing
to our economy continues so this isn't
an economy versus live conversation this
is a lives vs. lives conversation and
then what is what are those lives gonna
look like regarding freedoms that are
gonna be eroded during the snatch so
there's there's this is a complex
nuanced problem and people are just
making it oversimplifying and like oh
it's lives versus economy no it's not no
it is not don't don't call me like this
hypocrite that I'm being an [ __ ] just
because I'm bringing up the economy I'm
bringing up the economy because I'm
trying to save lives because I know what
happens look at Venezuela and ask how
many lives have been lost when the the
platform
the the strategic solution to this
economic disaster is socialism yeah well
one of the things that I don't think
people quite have wrapped her head
around so this is maybe two two weeks
ago I wrote something where I went back
and I looked at the Great Depression
unemployment numbers and in - in 1929
the start of the Great Depression
unemployment was 3.1 percent we were
just at 3.5 at the end of February so
very similar kind of very low economic
it went from three point one to eight to
15 over the next two years and then
eventually went up over 20 percent like
everyone knows and kind of cites those
numbers but three of the five years of
the Great Depression it was sub 20%
unemployment we already have seen in the
last two weeks
ten million new unemployment claims and
so we're already hovering in that kind
of seven and a half to eight and a half
percent depending on how you count of
what's actually been reported that's not
actually the true number because there
many more people who aren't actually
reporting it and so if you just use that
number let's just say that 10 million
people in the last two weeks have filed
for unemployment those are service
workers hospitality right restaurants
all these things tend to be lower
socioeconomic there's actually more
people who have lost their jobs than
would have been confirmed to have
coronavirus in the United States by at
least you know 5x and so it's just you
start to get into this thing of I think
to your point like the lives vers lives
it's not just a one for one we're
actually talking about many more people
are being affected economically then we
understand yet on the virus side and
that doesn't necessarily mean the virus
is it real or isn't bad it just means
that there's two sides to this
conversation and a lot of people don't
understand the second side or on the
economic component and how that affects
lives I'm just gonna I'm gonna add more
win to what you're saying here when
you're talking about unemployment
numbers you're talking about one working
body but that one working body typically
has two to three people that are living
off of them right
so if single household is gonna have
maybe you know 1.3 1.4 workers per
household so you do have stay-at-home
moms or stay-at-home dads and then they
have you know like what right now in
America we have 2.1 children per couple
so you know we're talking three people
per worker and when you're talking that
you're having three to four maybe even
five times the number of people that are
filing for unemployment then have Corona
that's just the people filing for
unemployment then you have to multiply
that number by another three so now
we're talking about you know maybe 30
million people that just lost their
source of income and then if we're just
gonna keep talking numbers of that 30
million people once that how long does
it take about 30 million people who were
already poor in industries that are not
gonna be coming back for them to be
homeless and then once they're homeless
how long does it take for things to go
really bad where you start seeing uptick
sand crime where you see upticks in drug
abuse you see uptick in suicide it's
it's it's work we're talking weeks
that's how fast that happens weeks one
of the things
I think people have going back to this
idea of like if you start with the slow
little stealing of freedom it also
happens with how people are told about a
bad situation so first it was we're
gonna shelter in place for two weeks
then it was let's add another two weeks
then it was you know hey here's another
week now we're hearing Virginia DC a
bunch of these states are saying June
10th and the reason why June 10th is so
important is if you go back what's call
kind of when people started to really
take this seriously middle of March
you're now talking about March to April
April to May May June so three months 90
days where those businesses are not
gonna be turned on even if they could on
day 1 turn them back on hire everyone
back and start paying them you're going
90 days there's very very few people in
this country who can go 90 days with no
income and be ok man there's people that
can't go a week mm-hmm a week like the
majority of so a guy is blessed me and
I'm yeah I'm not gonna go into that but
I right now and as I'm trying to snot
stay like in the black I'm trying to
like stay like out the line and hire as
many people as I can because I had
people even like in my immediate circle
that have been laid off had been
furloughed and they are they were one
week I mean it took five days of no work
for them to be I came in do you have
anything for me to do as like we'll
figure it out like yes let's yep come on
bro let's figure it out
one week now you're talking 90 days of
no income just that's a hard thing if
you've never been to work if you've
never like lived paycheck to paycheck
that's that's a hard thing to understand
where you get paid and you go and buy
like enough white bread the crappiest
peanut butter and whatever brand you
know from Kroger or Vaughn's or or
Costco not Costco so they can't afford a
membership can they get the cheapest
that will last the longest and that's
paid every single page
now you take one paycheck immediately
they don't have any food immediately so
now they would go out on the street and
ask for money or they'd go and get a
second job but there's nobody driving
and there's no jobs to be found so not
only do they don't have any food but
they have no additional opportunity to
try and to make up for that deficit so
now we're in the slippery slope of you
know 30 million people that are now
immediately stressed into poverty
there's there's there's not really
bouncing back from that when we look at
the similarities and the Great
Depression numbers on how long it took
for us to come out of that it's a
frightening thing so when you are having
conversations and people are having
conversations about lives versus the
economy that's not what it is you know
it's really like it's lives vs. lives
and freedom and you know I really do
want to highlight when you said like it
wasn't just shelter in place
it was first trying to practice social
distancing and then it was okay try your
best to stay home non-essential
businesses stay closed
then it was shelter in place and then it
was in some places um you know church
congregations not only can you not
congregate and social distancing if you
do here are the new laws that you're
going to be violating and it's like I
have a lot of land let's just say I
wanted to on top of this hill
put a big microphone and say alright
Church we can meet in my field it's a
beautiful day
I have exes and all the exes are
measured to be 6 feet distance from
everybody so you have to stand on your
ex we'll all worship together regardless
some Buddhist Hindu Muslim Christian
whatever that's took the point and like
we can't do that think about that like
the government has said that we
cannot assemble we cannot assemble even
in the limitations and distance we
cannot assemble in metadata and the few
ways that were able to converse about
this is kind of through social media and
that in itself is a limited form of our
ability of free speech because everyone
in those different platforms to
communicate has its own agenda and each
of those limits what kind of
conversations can take place and who can
be who can participate most so really
like the First Amendment is gone in in a
month it took one month for us to be
like ah okay we don't need that one
anyways we don't well and I think part
of this is like the right to assemble
right the right to free speech and you
start walking through and you said every
single one of these amendments and you
start to see how it almost feels like
there's an entire pocket of population I
actually don't think it's the majority
but there is a pocket of population when
you or I or somebody else says online
wait a minute
timeout you're violating the
Constitution by doing X whether it's the
paddleboarder or whether it's Rhode
Island you know you can't go to Texas
whatever the example is there's a ton of
people who say it's for the greater good
right and kind of falls back on that
fear and in this whole thing but what I
try to remind people is like the
Constitution is not a sometimes thing or
it's not a hey you can apply the
Constitution when it's convenient for
you guys but when you don't want us to
have the Constitution you can basically
take it away and that element of like it
is a persistent right to freedoms I
think is getting lost in some of this
because that that that feeling of
temporary component right like oh this
is only for a few weeks
to your point either one doesn't come
back or two there's such a loss of
freedom and civil liberties that it just
doesn't look the same when it comes back
know the you know the argument about the
code its hue in Instagram or Twitter if
you hashtag Constitution or Bill of
Rights you know your audience
mannequin alized you know that I did not
know that about me serious truck trying
to do the exact same tweet
and do like a hashtag Bill of Rights or
hashtag Constitution or both of them and
then do the same tweet without those and
see which one has more likes and more
retweets it's a fascinating little
experiment that you have to do you have
to kind of do it blind to your audience
so you have your legitimate so you'll
see in the algorithm that you're
automatically penalized for using there
so an argument about the Constitution is
anytime that it's brought up like it's
just a negated it's it's this yellowed
expired ideas that were that were
founded and written by a bunch of land
owning racists slavers well all is
idiotic but most importantly is that we
have the Supreme Court the Supreme Court
sole purpose is to view the Constitution
is a living document and they through
current times they apply it to what is
happening and how it is relevant to like
the current day current conversations
current vernacular is current British
everything about current makes the point
of the Supreme Court the only purpose
that the Supreme Court has is to be able
to interpret the Constitution to current
day so it could not be any more relevant
now than it was in 1776 like it is as
relevant in this day and as important as
it was in the founding of our country
and it is it is a very dangerous
precedent when we willingly the the
point of the Supreme Court is to be able
to somebody complain so me as a Texan
trying to drive to Louisiana or New
Yorker trying to drive to New Hampshire
and I get pulled over and I get arrested
and they say here is your ticket or here
are your handcuffs you're gonna go sit
in jail and then we're gonna move you
back to New York or hey we're gonna let
all of the prisoners go out of our Jail
because we don't want them to contract
Korona but then we're gonna be arresting
and finding people because they're
breaking our new laws and then one of
those released
prisoners comes over and raped somebody
awesome I'm gonna sue the crap out of
the government anyway eventually it ends
up at the Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court looks at what Constitution how the
Constitution applies to this argument
and but there's so many things that have
to happen before it gets to the Supreme
Court and that's the the [ __ ] that
ever-so-slight erosion where we just
lose these kind of microscope like the
tiniest almost in perceivable person
portions of freedom's granularly just
bit by bit we get walked back sometimes
it never even more more often than not
it never makes it to the Supreme Court
and the government and the local
government the state government the
federal government tries to circumvent
the Supreme Court because the Supreme
Court is the final authority on what
happens with the Constitution so these
three little text balances before the
Supreme Court is are there opportunities
to try and prevent it ever getting to
them and just being able to take as much
as they can
bit by bit and even the Patriot Act yeah
we keep referencing it so 9/11 planes
flying into some buildings right the
Pentagon the two towers a bunch of
heroes fight back and it crashes in a
field you know there might have been
another plane that was looking to go to
the White House and right after that we
realized just like in Pearl Harbor that
we were blind to what was really
happening that we that maybe the the
second worst intelligence failure of
since Pearl Harbor was 9/11 we knew that
there are these extremists that there
are these fanatic fundamentals
fundamentalist I hated our way of life
they had tried to do things before but
kind of unsuccessfully and so then 9/11
happens 3,000 people perished and it
gave the government every single
authority we it
We the People gave the government the
absolute authority out of fear because
we didn't want to see any more Americans
having to jump out of buildings and have
to make a decision do I burn alive or do
I jump to my dad we said no we never
want to see that again I don't care what
it costs
go ahead and do everything so we give
them access to our cell phones to our
emails that we had no expectation of
privacy through any communication that
happened not in person
and then we're like well wait what about
in person can the government be able to
wiretap things that would have been
private or the expectation would have
been private and what level of authority
would the government need whether it's
like a warrant or can we create a
different type of judge that could
provide those warrants in in like these
critical times as long as it's supported
this the greater good so we just like to
started handing all of these freedoms
away the motivation again was great you
know they wanted to stop a terrorist act
from happening we have never gotten
those freedoms back now if you know
we're having a conversation at the
dinner table and were like hey it would
sure would be great if if we went to if
we went to Disney World and and had a
great vacation there and then two hours
later I pick up my Instagram and so lo
and behold there's advertisements for
Disneyland and for Disney World and for
a vacation there wow that's fantastic we
know that happens right if I search it
cookies saved that was so invasive 15
years ago that would we would have never
imagined that that could have happened
but that would happen
I remember my grandparents when they're
talking about the government they would
take their phone off of the hook right
and then they would have conversations
sometimes they even unplug the phone if
they I know they they roll over there in
their grave if they could see now that's
what happens to that we willingly accept
this invasion of privacy that there's
not an element of our life that it's
truly private they
my my grandparents that fun who or two
would come and stab me in the neck yeah
one of the things that I really think
through is this trade-off between you
know convenience and privacy or security
and I think you're highlighting it here
of like we all want the cell phone so we
walk around with it because we can call
people we could get on the internet on
Instagram old stuff but it also provides
now a tracking device a listening device
etc I don't think we've really seen kind
of at least across the American
population in certain examples we've
seen it but not yet where those have
been used to steal freedom of movement
or kind of bigger kind of freedoms we're
seeing that now though where you see
Google creating these tracking tools
where they say hey we're gonna use the
cell phone data and we're gonna be able
to tell you are you social distancing or
not and we're gonna give that data to
the government and yeah we may anonymize
it we may you know kind of aggregated
supposedly but when you start to enter
into that world where now that data
isn't just let's start let's stop
terrorist attacks it's now let's prevent
you and me from going and meeting up
with each other really slippery slope it
seems yeah that's too far right we're
having private organizations that are
enabling portions of our everyday lives
and our like for me my phone is is how I
make my living like whether it's you
know through photographs or through
communication you know or through social
media and that they have they have
weaponized the phone where like the
distance of that I am from other people
how many people are with me what we're
talking about like what is next so first
they're saying how many people are
congregating at what distance and then
then are they saying okay well not only
are we gonna are we gonna be intrusive
about that let's also there here are
some things that they're not allowed to
do when they're together so they're not
allowed to what worship they're not
allowed to negatively disparage ly talk
about President Trump or President Biden
or whoever it's been
be like who knows like what once that we
keep saying slippery slope so that
metaphor is like after a couple of once
momentum negatively starts happening and
there's no way that you can stop the
negative energy that continues down this
slippery Hill so if this is a hill and
you're on top of it and then you make a
bad decision and you give up a little
bit of your freedom you're on this side
of hill and then you make another one
now you move two times down but this
look is super slippery and now I'm
sliding down and there's nothing that I
can do about it as I slowly go all the
way down this hairy troll ish arm and
fall off to my mouth and it and I think
that seems like in this alarmist thing
we're like no slippery slope
that's what alarmist that's what like
Preppers use as excuses to have a bunch
of chickens and have a farm and have
their own well and have their own solar
and have a bunch of medical talk about
myself right now and I'm super happy
well there is one one to have you come
on and talk about this right is there's
this weird balance between you're not
the guy who's yelling and screaming you
know [ __ ] the government actually you
are enlisted a United States military
you are a trained Green Beret Ranger
qualified you've spent you know what
almost two decades of your life
dedicated to protecting the American Way
of life American freedom etc and I think
actually what people confuse is like
those people who are in the military
police fire right all of those that are
sworn to protect the American Way of
life they actually feel the strongest
about this right they're the ones who
are saying wait a minute time out this
is not what is supposed to be happening
at home yeah but people look at my
resume and they're like oh that's the
guy that's gonna come kicking my doors
to take a gun like brothers
you're insane right like I have watched
my friends burn alive inside of vehicles
that got blown up by IEDs fighting to
protect these freedoms and you think I'm
going to go and enforce the taking of
those away from you you're sane right
like you're talking about the most
passionate
freedom-loving group of people in the
planets it is your law enforcement it's
your firefighters and it's your military
right because they have seen firsthand
the suffering and the sacrifice that
goes in to the protection and the
preservation of those things and for the
military especially we go to places
where these freedoms don't exist so like
every time I start having a conversation
about you know capitalism versus
socialism just economically or like the
practice of communism as a form of
government versus a republic as before
we have these have you ever lived or
spent time in that place that practices
the form of government that you're
supporting if you haven't why don't you
come with me for a few weeks because I
have and the whole entire time that
we're there the only reason I was able
to survive was because the military was
flying in my food in water because there
wasn't any there if you wouldn't have
got the water out of the the well you'd
have dysentery because it has been
poisoned by all the gross people that
are around there because there's no food
or water to be at and everybody's
fighting the same freaking well it is
clearly um i and everybody that every
single one of my brothers and sisters
that have has worn that flag on their
soldier on their on their shoulder you
have confidence that we are the ones
that loves freedom and that have died
and I've seen her and actually her
friends died protecting it and would
happily die to protect it so while I
work for Uncle Sam and I am proud to be
an American Green Beret and to be part
of the Special Forces regiment I am
first and foremost in American yeah one
of the things that really concern me
this is probably the most egregious
example I've seen so there's this guy in
Brooklyn FBI goes in and they've
confiscated a bunch of medical supplies
that he had right and and I'm not
talking about like he had you know five
masks I mean I'm talking he had 130,000
masks you know 600,000 gloves like he
had a warehouse full of medical supplies
and there's a it's a highly complex
scenario so preferred wood freaks out he
was selling them for you know seven
hundred percent increases in price all
this kind of stuff I'm gonna put all of
the medical supplies that whole part of
the conversation to the side
second but in there he got charged with
assaulting a federal agent because he
coughed in the direction of the agents
supposedly writer or allegedly and he
allegedly also said that he was positive
with coronavirus and the first thing
that went off in my head is is coughing
a going to be illegal in public right do
you kind of get so far down that
slippery slope where again in the age of
coronavirus where fear kind of you know
rains if you will all of a sudden can
you out like coughing right can you
actually get to the point where people
say hey I don't want you to cough in
public and it's actually for the public
good
if you COFF you've broken the law and
again it's an egregious example but that
doesn't seem too far off because it's
literally in an affidavit where a guy
got arrested and that's one of the
charges against right yeah have you seen
the videos of like the people
intentionally going into supermarkets
and coughing over the produce by the way
not not good I'm not condoning I don't
think you're condoning it right but adds
to the complexity of this situation is
when people are again being an [ __ ]
right and just doing things because
they're idiots
yeah it's [ __ ] illegal though you
know and you know the idea of I'm free
and I can do things that I want as long
as they don't negatively affect the
person next to me if I go and I coughed
on a bunch of vegetables yeah you know
fruit and that negatively affects the
person next to me I my favorite video is
the guy goes I think it was in it looked
like it was like in India the guy
coughed over a bunch of produce and the
shop owner went over there and his skull
stomped him I mean he just came like
just clocked him in the side of the head
that dude fell down unconscious and I I
don't even know what happened after that
I don't want to know but um like uh like
that pay problem solved I have no
problem straightening out but he it's in
front of me and you know and I will
suffer the consequences of what happens
if I have to like I totally believe
somebody can burn American flag like I
have fought for your right to do that
feel as if that is a protected form of
freedom of speech I can do that in front
of me I feel like I might be your your
teeth it I might do that and I've
realized that I would get arrested for
that and cool I'll take that happily you
know and that's kind of like where
things get complicated right where this
is where this is in this nuance the
subtleties of what is free what is
protected where I think we all need to
do collectively is really rally around
our freedoms and we need to logically
and rationally start looking at those
freedoms and figure out okay not for the
greater good but for my kids good like
if you don't have kids for your future
children's good
what kind of freedoms do I want them to
have do I want them to wait in bread
lines do I want them to be rationed a
certain proportion of water do I want
then like if they don't cough into their
shirt like this that they could be
arrested do I want them to be able to
hoard medical supplies we do we already
have laws that that prohibit somebody
from price gouging so like we didn't
need to create new laws to attack
somebody for price gouging like those
already exist like there's a guy that
had a huge storage of hand sanitizer and
he was selling them for $100 a bottle
well Amazon let the authorities know the
authorities shut down his Amazon site
and then he went and donated all of that
those hand sanitizers to local hospitals
and local schools awesome we already had
existing laws we didn't need to create
new ones to solve a pre-existing problem
and sickness is not a new problem
pandemics are not a new problem viruses
are not new problems right like this one
is not going to have like a tenth maybe
not even a hundredth of the mortality of
something like the Spanish flu like it
may not even have the same mortality of
the swine flu so take a breath
and start realizing how much we're gonna
be giving up for this for the peace of
mind of now yeah one of the things that
and I always should be really clear I
don't think you or I are saying like the
virus isn't real or it's not bad
right we both wish that the virus was
eliminated and social distancing all
these things are actually like good
things and and it shows that it works
and actually people should stay at home
and do all the things that they're being
asked to do that is being overlaid with
the freedoms but then people always go
second step and they say okay what
should we do and what I always point
them back to is I think folks who have
been in the military police fire except
for one thing that they've seen over and
over and over again is good leadership
and what I mean by that is there's two
ways to be a leader you can lead with a
carrot or a stick right and we have a
lot of leaders across governments local
state federal etc that are saying you
can't do this or you must do this
instead if we had a focus on more
inspirational leadership we're kind of
to your point if you do this together
our community will be in a better place
and you inspire people to do the right
things rather than saying we're gonna
put you in jail if you don't do this I
think it's a very very different path
that you go down but it takes strong
leaders who know how to do that in order
to get to that place in the world yeah
you know leadership is a tough thing
right now because we're looking at
politicians to be leaders politicians
are the most selfish people on the
planet they're there there's there are
very few politicians out there now that
are doing it for the good of others you
know you look at you know they're costal
Cortes is that where bartenders and now
they're millionaires you look at and on
both sides of the aisle I'm like I said
I'm a libertarian I'm pretty much right
down the middle of them both I'm
socially pretty left economically I'm
pretty right freedoms wise I'm like
pretty freakin down the middle um the
we're looking to politicians to be good
leaders but they've never led and now
we're in a now we're at a time
of a struggle and when you have to sit
there and say I'm in charge I'm the boss
here's the consequence of what's gonna
happen if you don't listen to me like
you've really realized that we have bad
leaders so as as we're moving into 2020
towards the election in November I
really really hope every single person
looks at their both local state and
federal representatives and how that
person communicated and led their
constituents and if you see this model
of poor leadership of them threatening
of them overstepping of them Liberty
grabbing of them taxi like those are
things those four right there are
slippery slopes that are very difficult
to come back so you know taxes and
liberties are things that are always
incrementally taken or added and then
can never be taken or or - did you see
you know did you see uh was the captain
in the Navy captain cores air do you see
this yeah thoughts on that and for those
they don't know basically a guy is a
captain on a ship he reached out to
leadership and it's unclear whether he
leaked that communication to the media
but basically said hey look I've got
people on my ship who are getting
infected with corona virus and and I
need help you know it's kind of an
overgeneralization but he was also
really relieved from duty you know how
much he can say but there's any thoughts
there so I have two conflicting opinions
about this first as me as a leader so
I'm a new Special Forces team sergeant
which means that I will have 12 Special
Forces 12 Green Berets that work for me
that they're my family I would do
absolutely anything for those 12 guys
and I really don't care a lot about
people outside the Special Forces
regiment because these got these these
guys are mine there's lots of guys like
them but these 12 are mine
and I would do anything for them to
include probably breaking the chain of
command to ensure that they're safe and
protected with that said I absolutely
believe that you should follow your
chain of command and that you should
push through the chain of command and
figure out solutions within the
appropriate like the the military chain
of command is tried and tested and
proven true and we have seen it through
how many countless of Wars unfortunately
and we know that it works because we
have used it successfully for like a
really long time to defeat people all
the way back to the British you stopping
communism stopping fascism and you know
stopping Isis so like you could do it I
know those sounds conflicting and they
may not be mutually exclusive but maybe
they are here's what somebody said to me
that I thought was a great articulation
I think it aligns exactly what you're
saying
they said he knew by breaking the chain
of command he would be relieved most
likely and he still did it because he
wanted to help those that never on a
ship and it was almost this like element
of I know what I'm doing is wrong but I
believe this is what I need to do to get
help and therefore he almost then got
what he already knew he was gonna get by
being relieved that is but yeah I don't
either
and if that's the motivation like kudos
the man's awesome
there's not many promotions that can
happen after the position that he's in
so there's and in retirement
they can't your retirement is whatever
rank you had so he's at the highest rank
so he's not losing a lot if he gets
relieved he also you know like if you
look at general McChrystal who did a
very similar thing he went to the press
I think he went to look Rolling Stones
and leaked a bunch of information and
you know his reputation was like that
might have been he might have been had
he continued without doing that regarded
as one of the greatest military experts
of this war on terror going down and
famous like a gallop on
but instead you know he's kind of
defamed but now he's like worth tens of
millions of dollars and so these these
arguments of like what what was the
motivation was this guy trying to be a
martyr so he can go on speaking tours
later or which he truly did it to be a
zealot and a protector for his men
possibly I don't know yeah I want to end
up real quick with there's a recent I
think it's a New York Times article that
basically talks about a number of these
private defense or you know security
companies throughout the Northeast which
which obviously you run a competitor but
but these companies are reporting you
know huge increases in interest both
from can you provide me bodyguard
services came to provide security for my
building
can you come out to my Hamptons home and
you know put somebody out in a car
outside to protect my family
and the thought process is a lot of
these folks are super wealthy and
they're worried about the looting
they're worried about the crime etc
first question is are you seeing any of
that kind of increase in interest and
then to how do you think about it from
your seat in terms of like is that
something that is possible here and is
this something that's likely so I'll
answer the second question first no I
don't think it's likely at all
well I think it's possible that's why
like I have guns and I have ammo and I
have a security system and I have like a
fence that you can't get through and
standoff and like my properties and
accessible and it's not listed like all
the things that I've taken to ensure my
family's protection like that's my
responsibility and I'm going to do that
to my damnedest I've also seen an uptick
like I can't even express like I can't
answer the phone or answer emails of the
number of people that are asking to that
and the hypocrisy of you know the the
Bloomberg during the town Town Hall
where somebody asked him okay how can
you be asking for populations to not
have firearms when you are protected by
people with firearms and he has had the
most hypocrite hypocritical response
where he says like essentially I need
them because I'm important and that
that is not that is not a unique
response that is that is a very normal
response from everybody in positions of
power
we're okay hey I'm gonna fight for the
environment and I'm going to you know be
like a tree hugger as best I can but I
am gonna fly them on private jets all
over the world but it's because I'm
trying to protect the environment right
so the hypocrisy continues down the same
vein of people saying no you shouldn't
have a gun I love that a lot of people
have gone out and bought guns for the
first time in their life and welcome to
the gun owning family and community and
I welcome you with open arms and I hope
that you take that responsibility
seriously because it is while that is a
freedom it is a huge responsibility and
that means that you have to be trained
that means you have to be able to to
store properly to protect your family
that you have to know how to use it and
when you can use it in all of the
different laws that exist like so
there's a ton that goes along
congratulations that you bought a gun
welcome to the family but now you have a
long road of learning what that means
but a lot of those people that have just
recently purchased guns were adamantly
against the private citizen being able
to own them and watching school
shootings happen and watching active
shooters and in malls and movie theaters
every single time one of those shootings
happen the government uses that
opportunity to try and seize more
freedom specifically around firearms or
ammunition so and you can go I mean very
back to the first one you know for you
can I think the most popular or
popularized one was was Columbine you
know if you go back and look at every
single one up until current day every
time that happens there's an there is an
initial rush to enact legislation to
create a new law to try and circumvent
the Supreme Court - okay we'll limit in
this way so we're not taking the guns
we're just taking the ammo we're not
taking the guns we're just adding a tax
so insane you can't even afford to buy
the guns because a tax that's already
approved so we don't have to go through
a Supreme Court but ultimately it comes
all the way back to where we at coba 19
where you're basing the subtle erosion
of of your of your civil of your
liberties because of your fear you're
looking at at the expense of the future
for convenience now and that's that's a
horrible horrible way to look at things
absolutely it's a thing where unless
you've seen it I don't think people
understand how important what you're
saying really is where can people go
find more about Sheepdog and kind of
what you guys are doing on the on the
training front and just kind of get
connected with you Tim Kennedy MMA is
all my social media stuff and my company
shaped our response we're on all the
social medias the website is shoot dog
responds comm we have frozen all in
persons live training for probably
another six weeks but we have virtual
training so you can like this evening
I'm going to be practicing some very
specific drills so by the time I get
back to the range on Tuesday I'll get
this much better you know incremental
improvement so shoot dog responds calm
and she got response for Twitter and
Instagram not tinder we're not on there
so are you on tick-tock are we gonna see
any Tim Kennedy and it's Tim Kennedy MMA
I was making coffee I've really just
exploring how to do it I have two
teenage daughters and you can see one of
them is on because I'm facetiming them
while I was doing a tick-tock and I was
like hey you're on tick-tock and she was
like I hate you I hope you actually said
some mean things something tells me that
being your daughter as a teenager is
probably amazing and awful all at the
same time I hope so that sounds perfect
awesome man listen I really appreciate
you doing this I think people more
people need to hear kind of your
thoughts on American freedom and civil
liberties and hopefully we can prevent
any more erosion but we're living in an
interesting time so I appreciate time
absolutely thank you take care
thanks Tim yep late